There are several different situations in which we might see equal signs. The
last case you did had an example of a conditional equation in it. Conditional
equations are true for some values of the variable, but not all. So, like we saw
earlier, this left side of the equation will be equal to the right side,
depending on what we plug in for n. Some numbers will work, but some will not.
Some things with equal signs will be identities. In an identity, no matter what
number you plug in for the variable, you will get a true equation. The third
case is that we might see an equal sign in something that is not actually an
equation. You've seen a few of these before. No matter what number I plug in for
y, over in this equation, I will never be able to make the left side equal to
the right side. We'll talk more soon about the situations in which these
different types of equations are used or at least, where these top two are used.
The last one is usually something that comes up if a mistake has been made
somewhere in our math.